INSIDE.
THANKS, CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
MARK PENN, DARRELL ISSA, TAMMY
BRUCE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
CONGRESSMAN ISSA, YOU WERE IN
THERE.
HOPEFULLY WE’LL GET THE
TRANSCRIPT TOMORROW.
I JUST WENT OVER THE PROBLEMS
WITH THE FISA APPLICATIONS.
IS IT TRUE THAT THE BULK OF THE
INFORMATION CAME FROM THE
DOSSIER THAT STEELE DOESN’T
STAND BY?
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
NOT ONLY CAME FROM THE DOSSIER,
BUT STEELE HASN’T BEEN IN RUSSIA
IN 20 YEARS.
SO THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE FOR IT
COULD HAVE EASILY IN FACT BEEN
AGENTS OF THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, WHICH WOULD MEAN
HILLARY CLINTON IS GUILTY OF
COLLUSION.
>> Sean: A GREAT IRONY THERE.
YOU’VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL, MARK
PENN, OF THIS PROCESS FROM THE
GET GO HERE AS YOU SHOULD BE.
I DON’T -- I BELIEVE IF WE HAVE
A DUEL JUSTICE SYSTEM -- I’M
LOOKING AT TAXI MEDALLIONS, LOAN
APPLICATIONS.
NO COLLUSION HERE AT ALL.
THIS HAS GONE SO AFAR.
I DO SEE ISSUES WITH RUSSIA WITH
URANIUM ONE.
THAT WE HAD A SPY WITHIN THAT
NETWORK.
WE DID HAVE A LOT OF MONEY
KICKED BACK IN THE END.
THEN I DO SEE ISSUES WITH THE
DOSSIER.
IT’S FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES.
THE FISA APPLICATIONS.
THE FBI USED IT AS THE BASIS OF
IN FACT, THEY NEVER VERIFIED IT.
WHAT JAMES COMEY JUST SAID IS
FALSE.
WE KNOW THEY DIDN’T VERIFY IT
BECAUSE STEELE DOESN’T STAND BY
IT.
>> WELL, I TYPICALLY URGE ALL
AMERICANS TO READ THE DOSSIER.
ANYONE THAT ACTUALLY READS THE
DOSSIER UNDERSTANDS THAT IT’S A
JOKE DOCUMENT.
IT’S A DOCUMENT FILLED WITH
NONSENSE THAT COULDN’T POSSIBLY
BE TRUE THAT ALMOST READS LIKE
AN APRIL FOOL’S JOKE.
NOW THAT WE SPENT, YOU KNOW, $30
MILLION, YOU KNOW, INVESTIGATED
MILLION, YOU KNOW, INVESTIGATED ALMOST EVERYONE IN THE CAMPAIGN,
ALMOST EVERYONE IN THE CAMPAIGN,
THE ADMINISTRATION, THERE’S
STILL NO EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING
THAT ONE WOULD CALL COLLUSION
AND NOT RELATED TO THE CASE.
IN ANYTHING, WE’RE DRIFTING MORE
BAN TO MONICA LEWINSKY DAYS BY
TALKING ABOUT PAYMENTS TO STORMY
DANIELS AND TRYING TO TAKE
PAYMENTS THAT ARE CLEARLY NOT
CAMPAIGN RELATED UNDER THE
DEFINITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN RULED
BY THE SEC AND TRY TO TURN THOSE
INTO CRIMES THAT YOU ASSOCIATE
THE PRESIDENT WITH.
IT’S THE WHOLE CREEP OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO GET THE
PRESIDENT ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> Sean: SEEMS THAT GREGG
JARRETT EXPLAINED IT WELL IN
TERMS OF THE LAW.
I WATCHED THE HYSTERIA ON TV.
THEY’RE SAYING CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATIONS.
I HAVE CAMPAIGN VIOLATIONS FROM
96 OVER HERE, 2008 OVER HERE,
BOB DOLE OVER HERE, AL GORE OVER
HERE.
THE BIGGEST FINE PAID BY OBAMA.
MY QUESTION TO YOU, AS YOU LOOK
AT WHERE THIS HAS NOW GONE, I
MEAN, I FEEL BAD FOR THE MEN
INVOLVED IN THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED, BUT I FEEL THEY’RE
VICTIMS OF WHAT IS SELECTIVE
PROSECUTION AND A POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT THAT THEY GOT CAUGHT
UP IN BY NO OTHER REASON THAT
THEY LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
>> THIS IS WHY WE’RE NERVOUS
WHEN THERE’S MORE REGULATIONS
AND LAWS.
WE WAKE UP AS AMERICANS AND
WE’RE BREAKING SOME KIND OF A
LAW.
BUT THEN IT’S SELECTIVE HOW IT
GETS APPLIED.
BUT IT’S ALWAYS HOVERING OVER
YOU, THIS ENTIRE DYNAMIC RANGING
FROM THE DOSSIER TO WHICH
CATHERINE HERRIDGE DESCRIBED
ABOUT THEIR WRITING IN THE
FILING THAT THEY JUST DID.
IT’S FAN FICTION.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ON ONE HAND FROM
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, OF
COURSE AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE THIS FRAUD, THIS HOAX BEING
UNLEASHED ON PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON.
WE EXPERIENCE IT ALSO AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN OUR DAILY LIVES,
WHETHER IT’S THE
DISENFRANCHISED, PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
THIS IS A CHILLING EVENT.
AMERICANS RECOGNIZE IT AND DON’T
LIKE IT AND IT’S UP TO THE
PRESIDENT --
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT --
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> Sean: HE CAN STILL RELEASE
THE APPLICATIONS, THE GANG OF
EIGHT INFORMATION AND THE 302s.
LAST QUESTION, DARRELL ISSA.
WE JUST HAD COMMENTS FROM JAMES
COMEY.
DO YOU BELIEVE WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT THE FISA WARRANTS WAS
ACCURATE OR DID HE LIE?
>> HE CERTAINLY IS INACCURATE.
THE IDEA THAT THESE THINGS WERE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN FALSELY
GRANTED BASED ON DECEIVING A
FEDERAL JUDGE IS MORE LAUGHABLE
THAN WHAT MARK SAID ABOUT THE
DOSSIER ITSELF.
ULTIMATELY THIS DOSSIER IS WHAT